hey guys it is Friday my name is jeff
mcdonald and I've got the five biggest
stories in gaming to get your caught up
on what's been going on
this week at Beaver 16 demo dropped for
pc xbox one and ps4 if you've been
holding out for the latest entry in the
massive eh soccer franchise you can now
try it out for yourself the demo
includes the standard kick off mode as
well as FIFA Ultimate Team draft FIFA
trainer and new skill games the demo
features 10 high profile teams and two
women's teams including the world
cup-winning u.s. women's team the three
available stadiums are borussia park
centurylink field and santiago ponovo
the demo will run up until sep tember 22
this week Microsoft stress the Xbox one
is not its own entity but is in fact a
Windows device during the city global
technology conference microsoft
executive vice president and chief
marketing officer chris kappa stellar
said a court our metric for us is
Windows 10 devices that's not a PC
statement xboxes today run windows and
so every time we sell an Xbox we're
actually creating a Windows active
device that could sleep people love it's
a gaming device in their living room
it's not a separate animal it is
literally a Windows device the Xbox one
is due to become more fully integrated
with Windows 10 or later
legal documents uncovered during the
unfair dismissal trial between bungee
and composer my peers Donnell have
revealed that Destiny's delay was due to
a reworking of the narrative the
documents claimed that the game 7 month
delay occurred due to changes being made
to the narrative they read although
destiny was planned for release in
September 2013 the story was
substantially revised beginning august
2013 requiring a new release date of
march 2014 and edits to much of the work
previously completed the game's
narrative troubled a lot of gamers since
it was perceived as being almost
non-existent in the game's most of the
law can only be read about in the form
of grimoire cards which are only
accessible on the web or through the
game cap it seems the kingdom hearts 3
want to be the next game in the series
to arrive as it appears that Kingdom
Hearts 2.9 is a thing that's happening
kingdom hearts fans like KH 13 spotted
an entry in the LinkedIn profile of Anna
soccerbase where UNIX developer this
best buy's working on Kingdom Hearts 2.9
for ps3 and ps4 where their duties
included overseeing the game idea
planning and documentation among
things the developer had also listed
kingdom hearts 3 development work on
this profile finally set a bridge Red
called The Witcher 3 a good investment
although it really was an investment as
its come out with the game cost
equivalent of 81 million u.s. dollars to
make c.e.o adam kasinski revealed the
budget during the studio's latest
financial briefing that hefty figure
included all development and marketing
costs but since the witcher 3 sold six
million copies in six weeks they are
doing pulley set aprox made a net profit
of the equivalent of sixty 2.5 million
u.s. dollars over the latest financial
period comparatively star wars the old
republic costs 200 million dollars to
make while Rockstar Games allegedly
spent 265 million on TV let me know what
you care to that this week and if you
think these games with pricey
development costs delivered this week on
site I tell you about awesome metal gear
solid 5 easter eggs on the chest lucy
gives me the lowdown on where the video
games make a smiling and we launched a
brand new show all about fallout 4 that
is everything that i wanted to tell you
about this week be sure to have yourself
a lovely weekend and I will catch to
begin on member
you